[音楽]
皆さんこんにちは
NPO守る守るの
西垣貴之です
私たちのNPOを守るを守るは
命を守ってくれている人を守るために活動
しています
共同代表の大浦一成は
デザイナーですそして私は
臨床工学技師という医療機器の専門家です
私は2000年から17年間
循環器の専門病院で
心臓手術に使用する
心臓と肺の代わりをする人工心肺という
生命実装地を
操作していました
人工心配は
非常に
操作が
複雑で
秒単位の
管理が求められ
注意するポイントが
無数あります
さらに患者さんの
病気や
身体の
特徴それに合わせて調整することが求め
られます
一人前になるまで10年程度
遊ぶ時間を削って
学位を取ったり
臨床研究をしたり
必死で勉強をしてきました
ですが
ほんの一瞬
気を許した
瞬間に
患者さんの
命を奪いかけた
経験があります
一つ一つは小さな問題でも
ミスが重なれば大事故につながります
命を救うため努力していきたい人が
命を奪ってしまう結果になり得るんです
私たちはそれを市のデザインと呼んでい
ます
実はそんな市のデザインが
医療現場にはたくさん存在しているのが
現状なんです
その原体験から
医療現場の
問題バグをどうすれば
抜け漏れなく
簡単に集めることができるのか
どうすれば医療現場以外の企業と
改善活動へつなげられるのか
どうすればバグを見ないへ活かすことが
できるのか
私の人生の大きなミッションの一つになり
ました
1つ天気となった
重要な写真があります
オペ室で発生したインシデントです
看護師さんが
患者さんの血液を
顔に浴びてしまいました
看護師さんは
患者さんに迷惑がかからないように
手術を優先し
作業を続けます
Cもそれが当たり前かのように手術が続き
ます
私は後ろで人工心肺を
操作していたのですが
強烈な違和感を覚えて
すぐに
血が目に入っていないか確認しながら
血を拭いてもらいました
その看護師さん
実は私の妻だったんです
その時の違和感を忘れないために
写真を撮らせてもらいました
女性は
感染すると
子供が生まれた時に
水平感染するリスクがあります
その奥さんが大きくなった時お母さんとの
関係がどうなるのか
思った以上に根深い問題だと思います
そういった意味では
男性よりも
女性の方が
リスクが大きいと改めて気がつきました
多くの看護師さんや同僚にその写真を見て
もらい
ヒアリングしました
メガネをしていればアイガードをしなくて
も良いそういう文化があることや
痛い
面倒くさい
曇るなど
様々な意見や
考え方が抽出できました
さらに医療現場以外の
友人に見せると
感染に対するリスクや恐怖心など
捉え方が医療者よりも大きな問題として
共感し
応援してくれる仲間が増えました
この経験で気づいたことがあります
一瞬を
切り取ったたった1枚の写真なんですが
様々な業種の人へ
店では見せるほど
写真から読み解ける情報がどんどん増えて
いきました
要するに1枚の写真の
情報は見る人の数が増えれば増えるほど
増加していくわけです
結果的に
irlを進化させることにした我々は
写真で様々な病院の
現状を
探り
共同代表の往来姿勢と
ミッションビジョンバリューを作成し1
ヶ月で
商品化のコンセプトを作成して10ヶ月で
上司しました
妻はその後
メガネの上からアイガードをして
いただけるようになりました
さて皆さん今から私が言う
状況を想像してみてください
1つ目
オペ室の床
電源が
絡まって困る
2つ目
子供がマスクが痛くて眠れないと
泣く
さて
皆さんが想像した床はどんな様子だった
でしょうか
皆さんが想像したマスクはどのような形状
でしたでしょうか
言葉だけだと
誤解が生まれやすくなります
言葉で説明するより現場の状況を写真に
撮れば一目瞭然です
それを踏まえてもう一つ
AED一般の人には使いにくい
皆さんはいかがでしょうか
緊急時に自信を持って使うことができます
か
胸骨圧迫を開始してください
音声案内も人によっては難しいですよね
AEDは
電気ショックの機械と思っている人も多い
と思いますその前に
心電図を測ってくれる機械なんです
必要な時だけ電気ショックへと進む
わけです
もし皆さんが大切な人に使えず命を救え
なかったとき
あなたは仕方なかったと諦められますか
AEDの死のデザインは解決しないといけ
ませんね
ちなみにAEDは10種類ぐらいあります
写真は
誰かが言葉にデザインしてしまう前の
生の情報が手に入る特徴があります
写真は
事実を
情報共有するという意味で
情報量と伝達速度が
格段に上がります
写真は一人で言語化できない
違和感レベルのバグを
専門分野の異なる大勢の能力を借りて言語
化することができます
さらに
写真をアートに見立てて
対話型艦長を実施することで人の視点
物の視点
プロセスの視点
五感の視点意味の視点
地球の視点あと未来の視点など視点を
ずらしていくことで
情報が掛け合わされていきます
写真や動画が溢れるまさに情報過多の時代
になぜ今出身なのって思っている方も多い
と思います
一瞬の写真に
複数人数で
数時間かけます
このプロセスは
イノベーションと同様で
既存の知識と既存の知識の新しい
組み合わせが
写真を中心に
写真の中で
再現されています
写真を使った対話型鑑賞のメリットは4つ
挙げられます
1つ目は
個人の共感力を引き出せることです
まずは個人で感じたことをすべて書き出し
ます
2つ目は
対話により
自分と他人の
感じ方の違いを認識することで
気づきを大量生産できます
3つ目は一人では言語化できない
問題を
チームで
言語化し
ニーズを創造することができる点です
4つ目はフラットで自由度の高い
安全安心の場が作られて
改善活動にも最適なチームを組成すること
ができるそういう特徴があります
現状では
様々な大学や
理工連携の支援機関
自治体においても写真を使った
ワークショップ
我々はticksonと呼んでいますが
これを実施し高評価を得ております
医療者が企業と一緒に
持続可能でクリエイティブな解決策を
探り始めています
医療現場のインシデント報告は
医療安全の専門家が頑張ってはいるものの
まだまだ
反省レポートのような
文化が
深く根ざしているのが
課題になっています
トラブルに直面し
心を病んでいる人がそのまま入力している
そんなことも多いかと思います
インシデントよりも
誰かのミスを防ぐ
ファインプレーに着目した方が
圧倒的に多くの問題を集めることができ
ます
一部の病院では
ファインプレーを表彰するなど
ファインプレーを集める取り組みが始まっ
ています
今後は
我々のバグを共有するWebアプリ
evergraphyを
現状の左ハットやインシデント報告の
仕組みに
並行して使うなど
仮説検証していきたいと思っています
私の行動指針は
シンカーというルーアーです
特に
考えているだけではなく一歩踏み出して
時には崖から
飛び降りるつもりで
チャレンジしたいと思っています
目標は市のデザインを撲滅することです
医療の改善プラットフォームの
新しい
当たり前を作ります
ファインプレーの裏側に潜んでいる違和感
レベルのバグをみんなで共有し
医療会と産業界の橋渡しをしながら
ワクワク
楽しみながら競争することで
命を守っている人を守れるそういう新しい
構造を作っていきたいと思います